nos piden que grafique mos la siguiente
recta y igual a un tercio de x menos 2 y
bueno siempre que veas a una recta de
esta forma se le conoce con el nombre
como recta pendiente ordenada al origen
es decir cada vez que veas a una recta
de la forma es igual a mx más fe vamos a
pensar en que se llama recta pendiente
ordenada al origen donde la pendiente es
lo que está lado de la equis que es un
tercio y donde la ordenada el origen es
decir b es en este caso menos 2 y se
llama ordenada de origen porque es el
valor que toma y cuando sustituimos el
valor de la x por 0 es decir cuando x
vale 0 este término de aquí se anulan y
entonces simple sencillamente nos queda
clic vale b y es justo por eso que se
llama ordenada al origen a la vez se le
conoce como ordenada al origen y bueno
la forma de graficar este tipo de rectas
es una forma muy sencilla porque ya
sabemos un punto el punto que nosotros
sabemos es que cuando x vale 0
entonces llévale -2 entonces aquí en el
eje las 10 voy a pasar este punto que
tengo aquí cuando x vale 0 que vale
menos 2 y no hay nada de mágico aquí
realmente lo único que puedes hacer es
sustituir este valor cuando yo pongo en
esta ecuación el valor de x igual a 0
entonces esto que está aquí se cancela y
solamente me quedaría que que es igual a
menos 2 y esto es lo que nos dice
nuestra orden nada al origen ahora
hablemos de la pendiente la pendiente
nos dicen que es un tercio y realmente
lo que nos dice la pendiente y déjame
ponerlo aquí este un tercio es la
pendiente y cuando hablo de pendiente a
lo que me refiero es cuánto cambia a
comparación de cuánto es lo que cambia x
es decir el cambio de iu entre el cambio
de x esto quiere decir que cuando x
cambia tres unidades entonces lleva a
cambiar una unidad y bueno ya sabemos
que este punto el que está en la
ordenada al origen está en nuestra línea
recta y ahora fíjate en lo siguiente si
x cambia 3
es decir vamos a movernos tres unidades
a la derecha 123 entonces ya va a
cambiar una unidad cada vez que x cambia
tres unidades y cambia una unidad y así
no podemos seguir
3 1 y ponemos este otro punto y podemos
hablar también para atrás podemos decir
que cada vez que cambia menos tres
unidades lleva a cambiar menos una
unidad e inclusive así nos podemos
seguir por ejemplo si yo digo que cambia
seis unidades lleva a cambiar dos
unidades es decir es proporcional menos
seis unidades en x menos dos unidades en
bien esto es lo que nos dice la
pendiente y entonces ya tenemos
bastantes puntos y la unión de todos
estos puntos es la gráfica de esta
función que es una línea recta y ya está